hey guys I'm just mcdonough it is the
9th of January and you're tuned into
games but news let's just say the voice
is an artistic choice in super weird
news that makes me somewhat skeptical
apparently playing video games for hours
can make you hallucinate this is
supposed to be Judah ultra visual
perceptions where real-world
surroundings become distorted after
playing games it's hard to put a lot of
stock in this one though since the
research conducted at Nottingham Trent
University only consisted of four
hundred and eighty-three gamers and
their psychological profiles would
included this becomes even more
pertinent when you start hearing what
they had to say which sounds to me a
little like trolling the hallucinogenic
experiences included seeing game menus
pop up in conversations in the real
world or heads-up displays while they
were driving I'm not saying I've never
wanted to harvest real-world plants
after playing way too much Skyrim but
this does seem to be a little beyond
that the university are trying to
explain what they're calling game
transfer phenomena which is how gaming
affects sight sound and touch outside of
the gaming experience what do you guys
think of all this and do you buy into
the possibility let me know in what
seems to just be a big bowl of
controversy gaming and religion are
being mashed together and as you can
imagine the strongly worded opinions are
running rampant this is all happening
because Phoenix Interactive Studios is
using Kickstarter to make a Christian
themed RPG called call of Abraham and
received an awful lot of backlash for it
the devil would like to raise Bible
interests and create a great game as
well as make video gaming a more open
space for Christian centric gaming do
you guys think this is a fair concept or
do you prefer your games without a
strong religious message let me know
last up oh how much money star citizen
has made I tend to avoid reporting on
star citizen since they seem to make
another million every week but Chris
Robertson's PC space sim has now popped
36 million in funding as a result
backers have unlocked the first of the
voted upon
called Tanza do you guys think there's
no way this game won't deliver all our
expectations too high you can let me
know in the comment box down below or on
my Twitter where I'm at Jeff McDonald
that's it for me today but I will be
back again tomorrow with my top 5 things
that happen from the week I'm just
myself and I'll see you again soon